what's up
guys bang bang lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rid of us just
trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful and annoying
oh i mean uh beautiful and intelligent
polina ivailova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
people told me to tell you that you're
beautiful no matter what your hair looks
like
and yeah thanks guys you know what my
mom always said
i got a face for radio no problem you
think that's funny
see you see how much funny my jokes are
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five go and get an
interest bearing account eight point six
percent apy go to block five dot com
slash pomp go do it i'm an investor i
sit on the board it's awesome they
literally just pay you interest you just
leave it in there they just keep paying
you interest
the first monday i think it is of every
month it's like interest
interest interest go get it up to 8.6
apy
there's risk to your research but check
out blacklight.com
can i complain to my friends yeah oh is
this going to be a
short show or a long shot a short show
okay let's go
so last night i wanted to make this
dish they should they should take away
my bulgarian card at this point because
i've tried to make it like eight times
and i can't
do it and i got burnt so i have blisters
on my hands
from now on i'm only using the instant
pot
because the instant pot does not require
an oven
and you are very kind because what i
made was not
edible but he tried to eat it
i ate it i ate it i appreciate it uh
all i will say is that this dish what's
it called
musica whatever is basically just you
cut up a bunch of stuff you put it in
there
and then you put it in the oven and what
i tried to explain to her
when i tried to explain to her is let me
tell you the american version of this
the american version is we would cut all
the stuff up and then we would cook each
thing individually
and then put it together you don't just
put
meat and carrots and potatoes and onions
and all this stuff
in there it's like trying to cook things
that need different types of cooking
all in one pan i'm not cooking ever
again like you see my blister yeah see
you know what that means we're gonna get
domino's and we're gonna get mcdonald's
it's gonna be awesome go check out
athletic brewing they're cool too
yes look i'm wearing a black shirt today
nice read the profile dot com
how many ads you think i could read off
we're good we're good the people are
good
okay twitter.com go check it out awesome
place
spack news jamal patilla
finds his next 10x idea with a 4.8
billion dollar spec deal for real estate
startup open door so he acquired open
door
[Music]
the open door is the online marketplace
for buying and selling houses and the
deal values opened
up 4.8 billion what do we think
people forget he did the kind of open
door
open door was founded by eric who's ceo
now
keith reboy who people always forget
when he was at coast la
he started this heathrow boy everyone
always gives him [ __ ] but i'm calling it
now
he is one of the best operators in
silicon valley part of the paypal mafia
i think he's a ceo
at square uh and he's a co-founder of
open door
4.8 billion dollars now he's an investor
at founders film that's right
but hey don't sleep on the results all
right
i don't know how this turns out second
thing do you want to the second thing
is uh everyone forgets chamoth is doing
this with adam bain
like adam payne's no sleeper he's on the
executive team on twitter he's real
so the first time i wrote about a spack
was a few years i think two years ago or
whenever it was
when chamath took a
virgin galactic public that was last
year the space tourism company but i
wrote about it two years ago when he
started the spec and everybody's like
what the hell's a spec and now specs are
everywhere
uh that spack is up 70 since they went
public
that's wild yeah so guess what bang bang
open doors now going to be public
this is a great deal it's basically
betting on two macro tailwinds one is
that uh
there's going to be a digitization of
all transactions so you can buy and sell
your house on the internet now
shocking move uh that's going to become
popular and the second thing is that
people are going to want to own more
homes and there's going to be lots of
mobility
people are going to be moving um you
know kind of all over the place so if
you're in california you're moving out
if you're in new york you're moving out
if you're in whatever state you're
moving just everyone's moving right now
and you've got that tailwind of the
digital
component the business will get better
it's awesome oh and
one other detail that i read the
internet uh the 4.8 billion dollar
evaluation i actually think is the
revenue they did in 2019
i did not read that yeah i'm pretty sure
but wouldn't it be more if that's the
revenue they did
no the point is that uh
that the 4.8 billion if that's true
basically they only got a one
extra revenue i think i read that i
could be wrong somebody correct me if
i'm wrong
go ahead what's next okay amazon is
trying to kill department stores
they're already dying so amazon just
announced the launch of its
luxury stores for designer fashion
brands
designers that have long relied on
struggling department stores to get in
front of customers are searching for
other channels of distribution this is
actually really smart
amazon's luxury stores will include
interactive features like a 360 degree
viewing option
which allows shoppers to see items on
different body types
in various skin tones you know that when
you see a little this is why i like rent
the runway
rent the runway has little pictures
right of like a model wearing
uh a dress and then you click
on all the user submitted photos and
actually see what the shirt looks like
or the dress looks like on real bodies
and like
in real light and it looks nothing like
it
are people taking photos like selfies of
themselves in the outfits
what's the incentive to do that uh to
show other women like hey this is what
it looks like
i don't know i would never do it but a
lot of people do it what would it be
weird if we took a picture of me with
one of the shirts on and then posted it
on there on your account
that would be weird okay that's fine by
the way amazon
how funny is it that they can't get the
luxury brands to
go on amazon because that would like put
down their brands then they just create
something called oh we'll just use the
same store called luxury stores and now
they all want to be on there
so is that right they didn't want to be
on well yeah cause amazon was kind of
like nobody wants to shop on amazon
oscar de la renta
is the first one to do right that's a
baller ass name oscar de la renta
is that that's a real person oh yeah i
was looking at some wedding dresses on
there
they were like 800 million dollars
we already got married you don't need me
all right what's next i got the cheapest
one next but it was so good
i'm gonna wait for that next all right
all right how do you pronounce this is
it nicola or nicola
i say nicola all right electric truck
maker nicholas shares fall as sec
reportedly examines
short sellers fraud claims this is
actually one that was requested in the
youtube comments that we talk about
so the sec is really looking into the
merits of a short seller's claims that
electric vehicle manufacturer nikola
misled
investors that sounds serious
that's what every short seller claims
here's here's my whole
perspective on this what short sellers
do is they are the
market check right they are the auditor
of the market in some degree they try to
go find fraud
and they are financially incentivized to
find that fraud and they put a short
trade on and they go there's two things
though
that are important um i forget who says
this
uh maybe it's jim chanos or i forget who
said it but somebody said
uh you know all the sec should do is
just go talk to the short sellers like
hey what's your best idea for fraud
and then they just go investigate those
companies because they're literally
the short sales are financially
incentivized to see this but hold on
time out time out it's not as straight
story as you would like to think it is
because what i do not like is that a
short seller can take a position
and then smash the company publicly and
the stock price falls they close out the
short
and then it's yeah i don't understand
how that's so bad so it's basically
they're
they're intentionally using press to
manipulate the stock price
and this is where you see a lot of these
founders getting pissed off
is because they're like this is nonsense
i can't go and manipulate my stock price
public like and go pump up the stock
price
but these people can take a short
position and then explain that but
but here's what's important in this
article mentions that the sec
routinely probes short seller claims
there's no guarantee that the commission
will launch a full investigation
but the report was enough to send nicola
shares tumbling
yeah of course if i was if i was how
much do they drop six percent
if i was a um i bet you the short seller
clothes they're
short if i was a founder i'd be so
pissed if this happened to my company
what i'd be like get your short seller
butt out of here would you sell
short shorts i would sell short shirts
that's what you all must i know i
remember
did you think it was funny not really do
you want a pair it'd be funnier if i did
it not you
do you want a pair yeah okay what's up
with social security
okay so there's about a month to go
before the social security
administration officially announces its
cost of living
adjustment for 2021 based on this year's
data one group estimates beneficiaries
could only see
a 1.3 increase to their monthly checks
next year
and so yeah seniors are
not seniors who rely on these monthly
checks in retirement might be in for a
disappointment
remember we got a federal reserve that
is literally saying we're going to
target we're going to intentionally get
above our inflation target of two
percent so if you only
increase the stipend by one point three
percent and there's
just two percent we don't even go above
two percent we just have two percent
inflation
yes next year and we only increased by
one point three that means we're
literally paying these people less
that's crazy by the way that's fine if
that's the goal
but you better say it well the problem
is
that what they're doing is in many cases
they're literally
preying on and they're stealing the
wealth of
the uh people who don't have the
financial education a 1.3
adjustment would also mark the fifth
time since 2010 that there has been a
small or no increase
yeah look again i'm not
upset at the decision they make what
upsets me
is you literally have a federal reserve
saying we're gonna go do this crazy
thing which by the way it is insane
and then you also have uh these guys
like oh well we just don't we
they haven't done it yet so we're not
gonna take that into account i see
that's what they're saying the average
cost of living adjustments since 2010
has been 1.4
right so if you think that inflation
well the inflation target is 2
they haven't hit it very often but
that's in the official numbers again
the inflation is not evenly distributed
among
the socioeconomic classes so if you're
rich you get very low levels of
inflation you don't buy inflationary
goods for the most part right it's such
a small percentage of your expenses
if you are not rich it's one of the
greatest
percentages of your expenses is in
things that have high sensitivity
but isn't it true that like this is a
public program obviously but if you work
at a private company they
adjust your salary based on so it keeps
up with inflation basically
not every job that's the whole point so
like quote-unquote the rich
yes white-collar jobs things like that
but if you work an hourly job at
mcdonald's you pay 10
an hour every year huh right i mean
when i was a kid they were literally
paying people uh at chick-fil-a i
remember
i was i think i was at chick-fil-a and
quiznos and quiznos paid me like
seven dollars uh an hour and chick-fil-a
paid
7.25 and i was like damn that's 25
cents an hour now they pay like 10 so it
does go
up i i'm willing to bet that
they don't
what is the average mcdonald's hourly
wage
they have to um
no it's we're looking wait really
that's not possible we
really welcome watch
you're watching her get red killed right
now she's got to get red killed right
now
on the the depths of american
uh inequality hold on a second
huh wait i really thought they paid 15
an hour no they don't pay fifteen
dollars now they pay minimum wage
really minimum wage is what what is amir
hold on
red pill red pill oh you stop talking
about getting yelled at but red pill
he says stop talking wow no that's not
right 7.25 cents an hour i've been
telling y'all i've been out here
i've been out here
okay so it's paulina's show now
i've been telling y'all seven dollars
and 25 cents an hour do you know when i
worked at quiznos
and chick-fil-a i literally worked there
in
2006. this is really terrible
14 years ago they are stealing from
people
wait seven dollars an hour is that
minimum wage
how is that possible if you all don't
like the content just come for the
learning
look at just look at this hermione i
really thought that they increased the
minimum wage
no they're out here stealing from people
in 2006
i worked at quiznos and i worked at
chick-fil-a and they paid me 7.25
the minimum wage today 14 years later
7.25 cents
so every single person who had a job
that's for the last 14 years worked a
minimum wage job
they think that they're getting paid the
same amount of money they're not
they're literally losing their
purchasing power every year
this is why the rich get richer and the
poor get poorer speaking of the rich
steve cohen agrees to buy the new york
mets in a deal reportedly worth a record
2.4
billion dollars i'm so upset that a-rod
and j-lo couldn't get the freaking mets
my work here is done i just feel good
that she down those minimum wages 7.25
i just can't believe i i really thought
it was at least 10.
how do you like it uh minimum wage seven
dollars 25 cents and steve cohen just
dropped 2.4
billion on a sports team by the way
great purchase
uh i the stat i saw was uh this is the
first time since 1980
john street capital uh a
pseudo-anonymous
suit anonymous uh said it it's uh it's
the first time that the willpond family
hasn't had ownership in the med since i
think 1980
which is pretty crazy uh and it's also
also also a horrible sports team like go
yankees
but that's fine we've had this
discussion before yeah the yankees are
way better than that i
don't know the difference or the sport
or why
if anybody likes the mets over the
yankees what is the little league
the little that's little kids that's the
one i like you like the little league
baseball edition okay well
little league baseball is baseball don't
they have other little leagues
uh no they like pop warner football
pop warner football is the league okay
so cool you don't like the little
six-year-olds running into each other
getting concussions
um so that so that's interesting for him
good for him that is not what i would do
with 2.4 billion but good for you steve
what would you do
oh i would first of all you'd go to
amazon's luxury store section
i would start with the homeless problem
in new york then i would make my way to
the homeless problem in california
then i would save some money then i
would invest some money
then i would you know just chill we'll
make sure that when you have 2.4 billion
dollars you
uh keep track of all the uh the
different initiatives that you
i will keep track okay what's next
macy's bang bang
macy's oh the only reason i put this on
here is because i wanted a humble brag
um so macy's
announces that for the thanksgiving day
parade this year it will be virtual
what is that insane the new york city
tradition is being scrapped
because of covet um for almost 100 years
now the parade has marched
the heart of midtown right up to macy's
but this year it will be virtual
this is so crazy do you understand if
aliens came down and they were like what
are they doing they got balloons in the
street that's weird
no so one time in 2015
i want to say i was a clown in the new
york in the macy's new york city day
parade
i got up i was one of those people
people are taking selfies with me
i wrote an article about it google
paulina manova clown
macy's thanksgiving parade you'll see
some excellent
photos yeah i'm not uh i'm not
contributing to this
it was great it was awesome it was great
right it looked
great hit me with your bad joke and then
let's go
what dial up internet over here
what do you call james bond taking a
bath
bubble oh seven
it's gonna crack that's literally the
dumbest joke i've ever heard
that like that was so pathetic
that we may cancel the joke section of
this you are no grinch
you will never cancel the joke section
the people love it and i love the people
that was so dumb i loved it
why was it dumb do you have a better
joke
what's your joke they're inappropriate
i'm not allowed to say you already told
me i can't tell my jokes on here cause
you said they're inappropriate
i got fired okay
guys bye see you're already laughing i
haven't even told the joke yet you're
already laughing
see you guys later we'll talk to you
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest account or you can buy
and sell cryptocurrencies on their
crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends